important why is it so popular why is it
so such such in demand for for people to
discuss
well I think it's been forced on us
which many of us resent
I think that the idea of
um
I don't even know how to put this but
I've been able to avoid UFO's Sasquatch
remote viewing uh ESP my entire life
with relative ease
and when our government takes a position
that makes it impossible to avoid that
by hiding its data
and making provocative statements
involving a thermonuclear
narrative
um you know the thermonuclear threat did
not disappear with the Cold War and it
is fashionable to treat it as if it is a
solved problem of our past when it will
be a problem throughout any future we
might hope to have
uh I come within